president biden is condemning republican
efforts to restrict
voting access calling it the most
significant test of our democracy
since the civil war more than a dozen
states have tightened their voting laws
since the 2020 election according to one
analysis
ed o'keefe is at the white house ed
there was also one key issue that the
president did not mention in his speech
that's right adriana good morning so far
he has not joined the calls to end
the filibuster that senate procedural
tactic that can limit debate
many democrats believe that's what's
holding up attempts to pass voting
rights legislation
without republican support but even if
the president suddenly endorsed ending
the filibuster
he'd have to convince moderate members
of his own party to do the same
21st century jim crow assault is real
it's unrelenting and we're going to
challenge it vigorously
speaking from philadelphia the
birthplace of american democracy
president biden forcefully attacked
voting restrictions being enacted in
more than a dozen gop controlled states
stand up for god's sake and help prevent
this concerted effort to undermine our
election
and the sacred right to vote have you no
shame
the white house hopes the president's
speech will jump start a push for new
federal voting rights legislation
but the bills he wants passed can't
clear the closely divided senate
unless it abolishes the filibuster the
president also directly addressed
unfounded accusations embraced by former
president trump
that democrats stole last year's
presidential election the big lie
is just that a big lie
the speech came as more than 50
democratic state lawmakers left texas
in order to stop debate on gop elections
law changes
the motion fails for lack of quorum they
spent their first full day in washington
pushing the senate to pass voting rights
legislation
we're just hoping to move the needle a
little bit more we're hoping that
congress would understand the urgency
this is about americans
the group met with vice president harris
and supportive senate democrats
what's happening in texas by the
gop legislators and governor is just
outrageous but republicans continue to
dismiss their d.c trip
as a political stunt it's disingenuous
and a down right and downright false to
claim that
any effort to prevent fraud is a veiled
attempt
at voter suppression and while texas's
governor threatened to arrest the
democrats
they said they're not concerned we would
not go to jail
so the republican-controlled texas house
has ordered texas law enforcement
to round up those democrats but the
texas rangers have no jurisdiction
outside the lone star state
if however the democrats were to return
to texas during the special session
they could indeed be rounded up brought
to the state capitol in austin
and made to stay there until official
business is completed adriana
wow ed you know another one of the
president's legislative priorities of
course
is infrastructure there was news
overnight that democratic senators have
reached a deal
on a three and a half trillion dollar
plan that they say they'll try to pass
without republican support
how can they do that exactly well we're
diving into the senate toolbox this
morning all the various procedural rules
they have there's one called
reconciliation
which allows them to pass a budget bill
with a simple majority
all 50 members of the senate democratic
caucus plus the vice president
in order to do that they're going to do
that now
by passing this bill and it includes a
handful of democratic priorities among
other things
payment for child care more funding for
child care expanding medicare
and addressing climate change it's
unlikely
that any republican is going to support
this plan
but it includes a way to pay for the 3.5
trillion dollar price tag
that is why president biden is headed to
the capitol today
to convince those democrats to sign on
anthony you could say
we're entering the arm twisting phase of
the biden presidency
all right ed thank you very much